foreign
Berlin distinguishes in his book two
concepts of Liberty between negative
Liberty and positive Liberty
negative Liberty describes the
individual freedom from something from
external constraint and from outside
interference it's the absence of
obstacles within a society
[Music]
positive Liberty means freedom to do
something to act upon one's will to take
control of one's life it's the
possession of the power to proceed
regardless of structural limitations in
society
sounds confusing the problems of two
imaginary people illustrate this
difference
this is Frank he lives in Freeland with
the two things he loves most his kids
and his weights and then there is Lily
she lives in Liberty values Justice
above all and dreams of becoming a judge
but both face lots of obstacles
to Frank there is nothing more important
than his health and his family he gets
up very early for his routines and then
takes the children to school he pays
strict attention to his diet and his
kids education and looks down on people
who neglect both
he doesn't like the authorities in
Freeland they collect lots of taxes to
fund the Public Health Care System why
pay the medical bills for those that
don't care about their health he wonders
Frank seeks freedom from these taxes
Frank Love still lift weights in front
of his house once the kids are in bed
yet recently Freeland prohibited working
out in public after 10 pm
for Frank that's none of the
government's business he wants freedom
from laws that restrict his recreational
habits
and there is one more thing
Frank also doesn't like public schools
he thinks they are useless and would
prefer to teach his kids at home but in
Freeland homeschooling is illegal Frank
thinks that is outrageous and wants
freedom from compulsory education
eventually he's had enough and moves to
Liberty where the taxes are lower the
government smaller and where he believes
he's got greater freedom from external
constraints
Lily is already there and feels trapped
Lily recently tripped and broke her leg
now she needs surgery but Medical
Treatments are expensive in Liberty to
pay for it Lily has to take out a loan
she thinks the system is unfair and
feels she doesn't have the freedom to
receive decent affordable health care
and things get worse
after her surgery Lily needs to
rehabilitate and takes walks around the
block this is when she realizes that she
hates the smoke from all the cars on the
street the smog she inhales is clearly
dangerous Lily finds she has no freedom
to recover appropriately
[Music]
this Injustice reminds Lily day in and
day out that she wants to become a judge
but since she's from a disadvantaged
family she can't afford the tuition fees
of a university and to take out another
loan scares her eventually she just
feels frustrated and bitter she thinks
she has no freedom to pursue her dreams
Lily isn't happy in Liberty and moves to
Freeland with a stronger welfare state a
place where she has the power to act
regardless of structural limitations in
society
supporters of negative Liberty tend to
sympathize with classical libertarian
thoughts they think of the state as a
coercive force that limits individual
freedom and prefer a small government
with few taxes and regulations
Advocates of positive Liberty tend to
identify as social liberals they usually
want a big welfare state that ensures a
fair redistribution of wealth and
provides equal access to opportunities
what about you which kind of Freedom do
you want for yourself and do you think
Isaiah Berlin's Theory the two concepts
of Liberty is right or wrong share your
thoughts in the comments below
[Music]
if you like how we explain complicated
ideas in simple cartoon animation you
can support us visit patreon.com Sprouts
just visit us learn how it works and
what's in it for you we hope to see you
there
and if you are a parent or educator
check out our website
sproutschools.com there you can find
this and other video lessons additional
resources and classroom activities
if you found this helpful check out our
other videos and subscribe if you want
to support our work join us on
patreon.com sprouts for more information
and additional content visit
sproutschools.com